[Applause]
thank you very much oh you're very kind
I'm yeah I I know you're excited
I know it takes a minute to sink in
doesn't it no I think I know why you're
excited today because Obama went all
black ninja on the Republican business
did you see this he Springs a surprise
climate deal with China on them he comes
out strong for net neutrality is gonna
issue an executive order to shield 5
million illegals from being deported
well where did this guy come from he's
taking them all on by himself he's like
Pacino at the end of Scarface you know
he's like hey Republicans here's what
you get for beating my ass last week
five million Mexicans what do you think
about it is kind of amazing what you can
get done if you just ignore Congress you
know it's like it's like when you tell
your kid 20 time to take out the garbage
and finally go I'll [ __ ] it I'll do it
myself
now it turns out that all those
Democrats in the House and the Senate
were just dragging him down suddenly
he's in an episode of The West Wing
I want plans for immigration global
warming and minimum wage on my desk by
noon and tell the speech writers to go
home I'm gonna write the Ferguson speech
myself what mr. president
they'll impeach you this isn't about me
CJ it's about a little Latino girl in
Texas who can't vote it's about an
elderly woman who needs a job it's about
a country that started to believe its
best days are behind us not on my watch
so if you're a Democrat you know you see
Obama as president Jed Bartlet's
standing alone for justice if you're a
Republican you see Obama as Bill Cosby
sexually assaulting the Constitution
sorry
oh yes I did
but hey the Latinos love it because you
know what Obama's immigration plan does
it allows parents who have Mexican
children who are legal to stay here with
them so we don't have to split up
families this is great news for arnold
schwarzenegger and it's made they're
very happy and an environmentalist of
course are very excited about this
carbon capping deal this is the first
time the world's number one and the
world's number two polluters have agreed
to limit the amount of carbon in the
future we're going to put in the
atmosphere and of course as you might
imagine Mitch McConnell John Boehner are
already criticizing the deal they say
any deal at Obama makes with China you
cannot trust a communist even if he is
your president
oh not the Chuck okay so the carbon deal
isn't perfect I still think it's better
than the alternative which involves
having Matthew McConaughey find a new
planet for us to live
but now what Republicans are really mad
at with this deal is that for years
decades in fact they've been using China
as an excuse to not do anything about
climate change cuz they're saying well
why should we do anything about carbon
China's not doing it well now China's
doing it okay cha and it also calls him
Obama got the deal done it took nine
months of difficult negotiations with
the Chinese president but he finally got
the Chinese president to come around and
that is something very unheard-of in
many parts of America a black man
getting the Chinese to deliver
[Applause]
of course now while Obama was overseas
on his big trip he's still over there I
think of course there had to be a fake
outrage the roie's is this year what it
was is when he walked into the opening
ceremony of the APEC meeting he walked
in with the Chinese president oh my god
he was chewing gum no chewing gum and
walking at the same time the Republicans
said this wasn't a blatant attempt to
show up George Bush and chewing gum can
you imagine of course the White House
they thought they'd have a little fun
with this and get the Republicans good
they told the Republicans relax it's
just nicorette gum that Obama choose to
ease his cravings
for white women